you guys need to respect Franklin
Richards check this out so Franklin's
Powers sent her around his psychic
abilities he's telepathic telekinetic
and able to produce concussive energy
blast he also possesses precognition and
astral projection but the most
significant of Franklin's Powers is that
he's able to warp reality meaning that
he's able to will anything he wishes
into or out of existence or change it in
any way he can conceptualize he can
create pocket universes he can resurrect
the dead he can neutralize the powers
and abilities of others like when he
turned off the part of his grandfather
Nathaniel Richard's brain that allowed
him to time travel he's turned energy
blast from a Celestial into a harmless
stream of flowers he's defeated Mephisto
in his own realm where mephisto's at his
most powerful he's even resurrected
Galactus from the dead and turned him
into his Herald he can increase his
durability making him impossible to harm
by all the cosmic entities and he can
increase his strength to the point of
killing a Celestial with one punch make
sure you guys follow for more